fashion food and new furry friends Megan
Markel and Prince Harry's three day
royal tour of Morocco was fast but
fabulous we're bringing you all the
details from their latest adventure
including the moment Harry asked Meg
who's the daddy the Duke and a very
pregnant Duchess touched down in
Casablanca on Saturday marking their
last royal tour before baby Sussex
arrived by going at the request of the
British Foreign Office one thing you
cannot knock Megan for is this
remarkable work ethic or her fashion
sense Megan looked radiant in a red
Valentino cape dress which she
accessorized with nude shoes a matching
clutch and our favorite ginger who
looked dapper in a light-colored suit
after being greeted by the British
ambassador to Morocco and his wife the
Royals were off to the Atlas Mountains
day two brought Megan and Harry to the
Moroccan NGO education for all a
boarding house dedicated to helping
teenage girls hid access to secondary
education the Duchess kept it casual in
a navy blue Alison olivia blazer a black
sweater by her designer friend and a
recent baby shower guest mission nunu
and hatch maternity skinny jeans she
completed her look with a traditional
Moroccan henna tattoo thanks to one
talented lady there was plenty of
hand-holding and the Royals got
particularly cozy while watching kids
play soccer but our favorite moment came
during a sit-down with educators when
Harry couldn't contain his playful side
[Music]
[Music]
that night Megan and Harry attended a
reception where the mom-to-be
took our breath away in another cape
dress this time a cream-colored Dior
gown which she paired with earrings and
a matching clutch the dynamic duo kicked
off their final day in the cutest way
possible
petting horses during a stop at the
Royal Equestrian Club the organization
helps children with disabilities through
equine therapy no wonder those ponies
were so sweet then it was up for a full
immersion experience at the and illusion
gardens in the country's capital of
Rabat yes it's crunchy and sweet and
salt that chef maja he led the food
demonstrations and tastings and even
cooked Moroccan pancakes from Meghan's
cookbook the royal couple also admired
local handmade products and we admired
Harry's sweet gesture when his wife got
a necklace tangled in her hair the
evening mehgan's long hair was swept
back into her signature bun for the
couples meeting with the King of Morocco
this was probably our favorite meg look
of the trip a super flowy light blue
Carolina Herrera gown with dark blue
details which Harry perfectly
complemented by sporting blue suede
shoes the Royals have since returned
home and the countdown continues to late
April or early May when baby Sussex is
expected to arrive when we'll make him
take her maternity leave
I'm told that she wants to work up to
her due date so really as close to the
birth as possible I think after that we
will see a lot less of the couple Megan
is probably going to take around six
months we think but already we're
hearing whispers of a tour in the fall
to America and Canada so she really
could be back to work as early as
October
[Music]